brigitte c'est pas dramatique encore les
températures ont la saison entre 3 et 7
degrés il a fait à château chinon et au
moins 120 103 degrés ce qui n'est pas
mal à châtillon 4° à nevers fin à mccoy
a offert 6 degrés et puis à dijon 7
par contre les pressions atmosphériques
c'est beaucoup plus sympa dire il a fait
1033 millibars à 13 heures et de partout
dans la région bourgogne alors pour
demain je suis sûr que tout d'abord
c'est le temps de cette nuit qui va vous
intéresser
eh bien le début de la nuit va être très
clair et puis demain matin il y aura des
brouillards givrants donc prudence si
vous rentrez demain matin demain matin
ensuite jusqu'à 12 heures vous pourrez
rester couchés puisque le temps sera
nuageux et l'après-midi allez vous aérer
un petit peu il fera beau lundi le temps
se couvre
il pleuvra bouge et on peut faire un
petit bilan de 83 rapidement il ne reste
que vingt secondes croise on est bien
écouter en 20 secondes je peux vous dire
qu'il y ait eu un printemps pourri qu'il
a plu trois fois plus par exemple à
dijon que la normale et qu'ensuite on a
eu un été pour équilibrer tout ça ce qui
fait qu'on a l'impression d'avoir passé
une année très mauvaise mais finalement
tout s'équilibre
merci on retrouve tout de suite les
pionniers de france de chenôve et le
conservatoire de chenôve jeu